Don't you just love it?
Love what?
Tiffany's.
Isn't it wonderful?
Do you see what I mean, how nothing bad could ever happen to you in a place like this?
It isn't that I give a hoot about jewelry, except diamonds, of course.
Like that.
What do you think?
Well...
Of course, personally, I think it would be tacky to wear diamonds before I'm forty.
Well, you're right.
But in the meantime, you should have something.
I'll wait.
No, I'm gonna buy you a present.
You bought me one, a typewriter ribbon, and it brought me luck.
Alright, but Tiffany's can be pretty expensive.
I've got my check and 10 dollars.
Oh! I wouldn't let you cash your check.
But a present for 10 dollars or under,...
...that I'll accept.
Of course, I don't exactly know what we're gonna find at Tiffany's for 10 dollars.